movement is how your brain knows you are
alive and engaged in life when you
exercise you see increased levels of
neurotransmitters that tend to increase
our willingness to cooperate and the
pleasure we get from connecting with
others that give us hope and courage I
mean even that lactic acid that that
metabolic byproduct of exercise seems to
have an anti-anxiety and antidepressant
effect this is like crazy stuff it's not
just an endorphin rash it's like at
every level of our biology when we move
our brain is like I guess we we have to
do this thing called life and so you
know for people like me who struggled
with anxiety or depression this idea
that you can convince your brain to want
to fully engage with life in a brave way
or in a hopeful way through movement is
so phenomenal